here's a couple things as we're wrapping
up i want to give you a couple updates
number one i want to give you a mafia
states of america update okay for people
that are still following that story fyi
if you haven't seen gerard on the
podcast for the last couple weeks except
for the 101 is because he has one
assignment and he's working with eric
and the team to finish up mafia states
of america and they're doing a fantastic
job i'm proud of the crew the product's
looking amazing i cannot wait to release
it to you i will tell you
this is not going to be on youtube
everybody needs to know it is not going
to be on youtube the only thing you will
see on youtube is a number of short
clips that will be shared because it is
10 episodes and we had a crew of i don't
know 40 people working on this project
this ended up being a half a million
plus of a project it will be sold the 10
episodes you can either be able to buy
one of them we haven't decided what the
price is going to be per episode maybe
it's 9.99 and you buy the whole thing
for 49.99 so stay tuned there will be a
website we will release we're getting
close to potential release like i told
sammy when he was on the podcast it's
either going to be end of the year
december or it's going to be 2022 and
what did sammy say let me just say this
it's gonna be the end of the year but
we're working on it to get it done for
you so hang tight with mafia states the
product looks
ridiculous this is all i'm gonna tell
you you're gonna flip on when they see
the product